THAT HOUSE HOUSE MINORITY LEADER
KEVIN McCARTHY MAKING HIS
MESSAGE TO THE ADMINISTRATION
PRETTY CLEAR DURING HIS VISIT TO
THE TEXAS BORDER.
NOW THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY IS RESPONDING SAYING,
QUOTE:  MEMBERS OF CONGRESS CAN
DO BETTER THAN POINT FINGERS AT
SOMEONE ELSE.
THEY SHOULD COME TO THE TABLE
AND WORK ON SOLUTIONS FOR OUR
BROKEN SYSTEM AND OUTDATED LAWS,
WHICH HAVE NOT BEEN OVERHAULED
IN OVER 40 YEARS.
HERE TO REACT FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR AND RETIRED ACTING
ICE DIRECTOR TOM HOMAN.
REPUBLICANS ARE MAKING THEIR RED
LINE VERY CLEAR AND THEY WANT TO
HOST MEETINGS AT THE BORDER,
SESSIONS AT THE BORDER TO MAKE
THIS A BIG ISSUE.
DO YOU THINK IT'S GOING TO WORK?
>> WELL, I THINK THE OVERSIGHT
HEARINGS SHOULD DEFINITELY WORK.
LOOK, GUYS LIKE ME BEEN AROUND
FOR 35 YEARS, WE WILL TELL THEM
WHO TO SUBPOENA.
WHAT INFORMATION YOU WANT
REQUESTED IN THAT SUBPOENA, AND
WHERE YOU CAN FIND THAT
INFORMATION, BECAUSE, WHEN THEY
DO OVERSIGHT HEARINGS, THERE IS
GOING TO BE A LOT OF DAMNING
INFORMATION THAT COMES OUT THAT
IS GOING TO PUT MAYORKAS IN A
VERY BAD SPOT.
AND IT'S GOING TO FORCE THEM TO
RESIGN.
SO I SALUTE McCARTHY FOR
DOING.
THIS AND I CAN'T WAIT FOR IT TO
BEGIN, BECAUSE MAYORKAS HAS
VIOLATED THE OATH OF OFFICE HE
HAS TAKEN AND HIS ACTIONS ON THE
BORDER HAVE FAILED, AS YOU KNOW,
LAWRENCE, EVERY MONTH A RECORD
NUMBER.
HE HAS FAILED FOR 18 MONTHS.
TIME FOR HIM TO GO.
>> Lawrence: TOM, I MADE THIS
POINT ON "THE FIVE" LAST NIGHT
THE BORDER IS THE SCENE OF THE
CRIME.
SEE WHAT HAPPENS THERE.
TAKE THEM TO THE BIG BEND SECTOR
SMELL THE BODIES THAT ARE
ROTTING.
YOU KNOW THEY ARE THERE BUT YOU
CAN'T FIND THEM BECAUSE THEY ARE
ALL OVER THE PLACE.
SEE WHAT THESE CHILDREN WHO ARE
DROWNING.
HOW ABOUT THEY DRAIN THE RIO
GRANDE SO THEY CAN SEE HOW MANY
BODIES THAT ARE BURIED THERE?
HOW ABOUT THEY GO TO ONE OF
THOSE SEMI-TRUCKS AND STAY IN
THERE FOR THREE MINUTES SO THEY
CAN SEE WHAT THEY ARE
ENCOURAGING THE ILLEGAL MIGRANTS
TO DO.
>> I DOUBT YOU WILL SEE A SINGLE
DEMOCRAT CONGRESSMAN DO THAT
THEY RAN DOWN TO THE BORDER
UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP WHEN TWO
CHILDREN DIED.
NOW WE GOT OVER 100 MIGRANTS
HAVE DIED ON U.S. SOIL.
WHERE ARE THEY?
WHERE IS CONGRESSMAN CASTRO.
WHERE IS CONGRESSWOMAN AOC WHO
WENT DOWN AND SCREAMED UNDER THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
THEY ARE IGNORING THE CLEAR
DATA.
LOOK AT THE DEPARTMENT STATEMENT
HAD THEY PUT OUT SAYING THEY ARE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE
WORKFORCE.
LET'S REMEMBER, WORK FORCE, LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND TURNED
THEM INTO A TOURIST AGENCY.
PROCESSING PEOPLE, RELEASING
PEOPLE AND TAKING THEM TO AN
AIRPORT AND FLYING THEM A CITY
OF THEIR CHOICE.
NOT ONLY THAT, HE STOOD AT THE
WHITE HOUSE PODIUM AND SLANDERED
THE MEN AND WOMEN OF THE HORSE
PATROL WHEN HE KNEW THEY WERE
INNOCENT, HE NEEDS TO GO.
HE HAS NO RESPECT TO THE
WORKFORCE, THE WORKFORCE HAS NO
RESPECT IN HIM.
>> Lawrence: IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
TOM, ANOTHER THING I WANTED TO
GET TO YOU REACT TO ACCORDING TO
THE BOSTON HERALD, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS SET TO DEPLOY
AIR MARSHALS TO HELP WITH THE
BORDER TO HELP WITH MIGRANTS
WEDNESDAY.
I MEAN, WHAT ARE THEY DOING?
>> WHY DO THEY NEED AIR
MARSHALS?
HE JUST SAID THE BORDER IS
SECURED AND THE BORDER IS
CLOSED.
WHY DO YOU NEED MORE PEOPLE DOWN
THERE?
TELL YOU WHY THEY ARE SENDING
FOR PEOPLE DOWN THERE TO PROCESS
QUICKER AND RELEASE QUICKER.
THEY DON'T WANT THE OPTICS OF
OVERCROWDED IF THEY DON'T HAVE
OVERCROWDING THERE IS NOT AN
ISSUE.
MAYORKAS CAN KEEP LYING TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT THE BORDER
IS SECURE.
HE ISN'T SENDING ONE OFFICER
DOWN THERE TO ENFORCE THE LAW
AND SECURE THE BORDER.
HE IS SENDING THEM THERE TO
PROCESS QUICKER, RELEASE QUICKER
SO HE CAN CONTROL THE OPTICS OF
THIS CRISIS THIS IS INSULTING TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AGAIN.
NEEDS TO BE IMPEACHED.
I CALLED FOR IT FOR OVER A YEAR.
I'M GLAD CONGRESS HAS FINALLY
TAKEN SO